jessica fowler was only four when she
entered the child welfare system
a bright-eyed preschooler who would be
separated from her sisters bounced
between homes 15 times
including ones where she says she was
abused starved and beaten there's
nothing i could do about my situation
it's
really scary
when you're
in it because you don't know where
you're going
i'm sorry
but it was a group home in ottawa where
she arrived at 16 she says was the most
violent i had to go through this just
because like i didn't have parents
i mean it's not normal
yeah it's just it's just not normal
it was run by a private company called
mary homes which operates five group
homes in the area
there are no foster parents here shift
workers and youth in care come together
under one roof
there was no shoes at the entrance
as they had them locked up
the shoes were locked up
why so like kids couldn't run
teens who've lived there say bedroom
windows were nailed shut and food was
locked away
so this is a prison viewer this is my
prison
inside the group home jessica
felt trapped that's my room
that's the door
flocked so i can't leave
jessica lived at two different mary
homes sites where she says she was
threatened ridiculed and repeatedly
physically restrained by workers
tackled to the ground for things as
simple as making toast at the wrong time
i was just like
listen i will go to my room as soon as
like i can get my food and they're like
no you'll go now and they start like
trying to drag me down the stairs
pulling on my shirt choking me and they
were like kind of like clawing at me to
get me like to like force me into my
room
and they went to put me in this like
restraint and they pushed my face into
like my mattress and i couldn't breathe
at all like i was trying to like scream
to communicate that like i was having a
hard time breathing and i couldn't say
anything
eventually like they let me off
and then they took it to the floor so
they restrained you on the bed and then
they moved you to the floor and kept
restraining you yeah i never
felt that before like
i couldn't breathe
delana land was already living at the
group home when jessica arrived
delena got there in late 2015 an
indigenous teen nearly 2 000 kilometers
from her first nation in northern
ontario
the first time she says she was
restrained at mary homes was less than
two weeks after she arrived i was
reading a book past lights out and then
i kept telling them that i just wanted
to keep it all longer i'm not tired i'm
being quiet i'm reading a book
shift that on my hand and said i was
like resisting and then she just like
stepped on my back and then just kind of
just went down
sorry
she stepped on you yes and then i was on
the floor and then she was like let me
know when you're gonna behave then i'll
show you on the floor for like 20
minutes
she kept her foot on your back for 20
minutes yeah for reading a book to
reading a book
delana says a pattern developed where
workers restrained her as often as three
times a week for just many ridiculous
reasons for swearing being loud
for being destructive just anything we'd
get restrained
the child welfare system operates
largely in secret
there is little public transparency on
how some of the most vulnerable kids are
treated inside foster care and group
homes
which is why a team from global news and
aptn used the freedom of information law
to access and analyze more than 10 000
serious occurrence reports from the
child welfare system in ontario from a
one year period in 2020 and 2021
the data was revealing
at some group homes and foster homes
there was an alarmingly high number of
serious incidents reported
including deaths injuries missing kids
and restraints
and the data also suggests systemic
issues at companies with multiple homes
where there was a pattern of serious
occurrences and restraints across many
locations that really is a clear-cut
issue of a service provider really not
doing the work kiara scarabagi is the
dean of the faculty of community
services at toronto metropolitan
university
not every serious occurrence means that
somebody's doing something wrong however
if everybody runs away all the time why
doesn't anybody want to be here we
assume it's the kids who have a problem
when in fact those young people might be
doing the right thing running away from
a harmful place
at mary homes 58 percent of its serious
occurrence reports were for physical
interventions otherwise known as
restraints
a last resort the government only
permits when children pose an immediate
risk to themselves or others restraints
are considered therapeutic interventions
in fact i think restraints are acts of
violence certainly the young people will
tell you that they're experienced as
acts of violence and so we have an
official system like this is a publicly
regulated system in which institutional
violence
is considered normal and good
no one from mary homes would answer our
questions but the ministry of children
community and social services has
imposed conditions on its group home
licenses effective january of this year
including no longer locking up kids
shoes
and providing an updated policy on
restraints outlining when they are
permitted
we have
a whole group of kids
who may or may not
be safe
the president of the ontario association
of child and youth care kuran yang
says the data from the series occurrence
reports or sors
is telling when you have an incredibly
high instance of sors
you need to look very closely because it
could be an indicator
that you have
incorrectly improperly trained
practitioners who are
inadvertently escalating behavior
kura's association has been advocating
for two decades that workers be required
by law to have completed a public
college or university program in child
and youth care so in the worst case
scenario today we have you know
frontline workers where the minimum
qualification is that they have a
driver's license and perhaps a high
school diploma
this is an ad for a child and youth
worker in northern ontario from last
summer
the role
one-on-one supervision of high risk and
special needs children
the qualifications needed
a driver's license and a criminal record
check
starting in july 2023 the ontario
government will require group home
workers have a diploma degree or
certificate in a relevant field
or prior experience deemed relevant
but it falls short of requiring that
training be in child and youth care
cassandra murphy worked at group homes
run by interphase child and family
services from 2011 to 2014.
interphase requires a diploma or degree
in a social services related field so
with a diploma in corrections cassandra
was hired did anybody say to you hey you
don't have any training in child and
youth work nope wasn't a problem nope
looking back she says she didn't have
the right training
and now lives with regret guilt and
sadness
how frequently would these restraints
happen daily multiple times a day with
different different kids multiple times
a day yes you would restrain a child yes
which to me might say maybe this isn't
the right environment for them
interphase had the highest number of
serious occurrence reports of any group
home operator in ontario according to
global news's analysis
and more than half of those reports were
for workers restraining kids and youth i
think that it shows that our first
response is to go hands-on with the
child rather than take the time to maybe
educate ourselves
into properly ensuring these kids are
growing up in a normal environment
interface declined an on-camera
interview but said in a statement it
over-reports in the interest of
transparency and cares for hard-to-serve
youth it also said restraints are only
used in high-risk situations where there
is a physical threat
and in roughly 10 percent of cases
restraints involved a staff member
holding onto a child's
hand the year after cassandra left
interphase a 17 year old boy with a
developmental disability named justin
san giuliano died after being restrained
in one of its homes
in response interphase stated publicly a
goal of reducing restraint
but by 2021 the volume actually
increased
interphase now says it's launched a
restraint reduction plan and has updated
staff training there was literally no
need for any of it
for black and indigenous youth like
delena who are vastly overrepresented in
care the overuse of restraints is a
continuation of generations of trauma
when you think about the violence
associated with physical interventions i
can think of no context in which we have
made it
okay to engage in this kind of violence
publicly
other than the context of doing so
against
black people and indigenous people
child welfare is implicated in indian
residential schools it was responsible
for the 60s scoop char welfare was built
on the on the foundation of racism
among the indigenous youth the system
has failed
amy owen
in good faith
a teen from poplar hill first nation in
far northwestern ontario
amy died by suicide inside a mary homes
residence in 2017.
jessica and elena live there at the same
time she got restrained for talking back
she got grounded for cutting herself she
like it's just anything delaina says amy
was like her little sister and the pair
had a pact to get out of mary homes
today is april eight
i think it's like three o'clock
ish
it's day one
i was saving my bus tickets so i can
take her to awol with me because i know
she's been going through a lot when you
say awol that's a group home term for
leaving to run away yeah and i kept
telling her we're going to take off
and she died on the 17th and then i took
off on the 20th
i still did it because i knew she she
wanted it where did you go
i love the stairwell the mall yeah so to
you living in a stairwell was better
than living in mary homes yeah
at least i was able to be me i was able
to be okay
for jessica who stayed at the group home
after amy's death the anguish was
overwhelming and she says there was
little compassion i didn't understand
what i was like going through
that
[Music]
that i was like
suffering from ptsd i didn't know that
but they would just say that it was
attention seeking
and so in a cry in the dark she wrote
out her pain on paper
[Music]
when you're a kid you don't know how to
handle your emotions or deal with what
you're going through
and the only thing you can do is kind of
just run
[Music]
much of what happens inside group homes
and foster care homes is shared in
whispers the kids and teens who've
experienced it like delana land know
what it's truly like
if i was bad i get tossed into somewhere
where if i was good i get put into a
nice home
but the public doesn't know
inspection reports are kept private the
reasoning it's done for the protection
of kids
but sometimes it's protecting bad
operators
kiara scarabagi is a professor of child
and youth care in toronto right now as
we're having this conversation there is
a young person in a group home somewhere
who's hungry and not allowed to get food
there are young people everywhere in the
province who are moving today from one
placement to another with all of their
belongings jammed into garbage bags it's
a system that doesn't really focus on
the dignity and the care and the
well-being of young people
using the freedom of information law
global news and aptn obtained dozens of
ministry inspection reports from group
homes and foster care homes across the
province
among the inspectors findings homes in
states of disrepair and kids who
couldn't get basic medical care
nutrition or clothing at one group home
a youth with an impacted tooth was told
to wait six months for treatment because
of a lack of insurance at another kids
relied on food donations from the local
church for meals
sometimes kids reported being hungry and
didn't have access to the kitchen
and in one case a child had to sleep on
a blow-up mattress
soiled and smelling of urine it's cruel
it's cruel i think you've discovered and
i'm confirming for you that it is
incredibly bad for many young people
some of the worst conditions were found
in group homes group homes today are
seen as the placement of last resort
young people know what that means that
means we don't know what to do with you
we can't really help you
let's hope nothing terrible happens
nearly half of all group homes in
ontario are run by for-profit companies
the average cost of a group home bed is
more than three hundred dollars a day
per child but for kids who require more
support like one-to-one staffing the
cost can skyrocket in one instance we
found more than twelve hundred dollars a
day
nobody can tell me that when that much
money is involved
that the decision-making
centers the well-being of the child
these things are about a commodity that
is very valuable
the oversight of how the money is spent
and how kids are cared for falls to both
the ministry which licenses companies
and children's aid societies which
ultimately place kids in homes
but when one of them falls short like
delana's children's aid worker who was
required to check on her at regular
intervals there are seemingly few
consequences
when you were at mary homes there was no
children's aid society worker who came
to check on you to make sure that you
were okay and happy in that place nope
nobody physically came in that house
nope they didn't even give me a worker
here in ottawa
the ontario association for children's
aid societies wouldn't comment on
individual cases but says its priority
is reducing the use of group care
the ministry of children community and
social services meanwhile says it's
reviewing the process for inspections so
that it can strengthen them where
necessary
there is not enough oversight
kuren yang is the president of the
ontario association of child and youth
care are we holding people accountable
for the quality of care we're giving to
these kids today in ontario no
for years successive provincial
governments have had a roadmap for how
to fix things reports blueprints even a
review of the entire system it
commissioned with over 30
recommendations
guiaris co-authored that report we
proposed very concretely a mechanism by
which one could really exercise
meaningful oversight
with young people participating with
families of those young people also
participating and with service providers
participating
none of that has happened
the province now says it's undertaking a
multi-year child welfare redesign
including amendments to regulations
which will help clarify the rules around
restraints require more detailed and
extensive plans of care and engage kids
and youth in decision making
the new rules will come into effect in
just over a year
they should just
care
and love us more the way they're
supposed to then
treat us like
more wild animals
the group home where all three girls
lived run by mary homes stopped
operating after amy owens death though
the company continues to accept kids and
youth at its other locations
today delana is living independently
with her four-year-old son
she hopes to get her high school diploma
in the fall
so she can start studying to become a
dental hygienist
[Music]
as for jessica fowler after she left
mary homes she was placed in a foster
home that finally felt safe
a home she says
that's become
family
do you feel happy today
yeah i do
now she hopes
the pain of the youth who have survived
the system can teach those in positions
of power how to fix it
it breaks my heart that my bed was
basically replaced with another kid
who's in the same situation
that i was in
young people have to be the drivers of
change in the system adults have tried
we've tried for 20 years to make the
system better be failed
give it to young people give the system
to young people and let them drive the
change if there is one thing i would put
my trust in it said young people will
know what to do